i agree but sometimes my ads are funny
like i have people that get mad at me on
the picture because i don't do ads
because they go your ads are funny like
my ads are funny
i'm sure that i do ridiculously funny
i'll be pissed if i
sometimes the companies get mad but
sometimes they like it like sometimes
they get it i know me
i sell a lot of [ __ ] like we sell a lot
of magic explain cereal i hear you but
it's like i also go crazy yeah and
they're cool most of them are cool with
it most of them are cool and they get it
but
some kind of laughter monday.com got mad
do they advertise
monday.com no because at the end of the
year i still don't know what this is
monday.com is like if you have a company
from five to a thousand people but don't
know how to send emails
we will organize i'm like yeah i'm sure
there's a lot of thousand person
companies that can't figure out how to
get everyone in a meeting
dude what we did a reading who's that
for
me and brian did a read for a toyota
yeah they launched a podcast
did do we release this as a cartoon
animation
but it never happened we were doing this
ad and i'm like
hold on timmy toilet has a podcast
that's crazy it's on their cars it's
like
haven't you always just been clamoring
for how the camera came about
oh dude no me and brian we could not get
through the read we were laughing
so hard but we're going to release that
i don't think they ever paid us or
came back again but it was so [ __ ] i
have it too if you want to
have it yeah you know the beginning yeah
play it if you guys please
play it just like doesn't have this gym
of course years ago
years ago and this was you
advertising a podcast of toyota
this is a really a toyota podcast
who the [ __ ] gonna listen maybe yeah
you ever
just sit around while you're scrolling
through some of your podcasts and going
you know what man
toyota just isn't a car company they're
not saying that all the time i go what
else they are though you know what they
are their new podcast called toyota
[Music]
untold
dude
we didn't know what it was to insure
that's crazy
oh my god i can do this okay
baby
that's so funny let's do this hey who
gives a [ __ ] if we [ __ ] up you ready
you ready hey
yeah what's up buddy damn bro you know
what man
yeah it's hard it's hard keep going it's
hard to do
dude but so you got gotta do it
sometimes a total podcast
yeah what were they thinking and which
one of our listing like oh
a podcast on the history of toyota yeah
sign us up
let's do it i want to know how the
corolla happened
it's sad but a lot of the companies are
cool with
with the crazy ads i do and it's like
funny pull up tim dillon dark
wicks ad what they do what they don't
realize is a minute that is fun allowing
us to be as free and creative as we want
is what's going to sell their product if
it
gets really funny like me and theo did
one on on uh
postmates yeah and we thought they're
gonna be mad they're like dude we've
never seen such a retreat this sold
things like i do ads like this but this
sold this actually worked this guy the
number four yeah yeah
it's actually this was like everybody
we have talked at length about the
importance
of having a website it is something that
i think is essential for people no
matter how worthless you
are no matter how worthless your product
is
no matter how much talent you lack
it's a great place to put all of it
it doesn't matter if you're good or bad
this society is no longer run according
to that
little nazax put a song on tick tock it
was like this goofy song
and now he's a millionaire he's gay
why so just imagine like you're in wix
and you're like okay who's doing this
new ad and it's a five minute day but
it's just a funny like
it's just like that's what makes me
laugh yeah it's just funny check it out
yeah i would check it out you've been
like wix are you looking for a website
yeah and i also put them in the middle
of the show so it's like i make them
flow with the show
so yeah it has to flow with the show and
be on the screen
so if i'm not making you laugh or i'm
not having fun why am i doing you know
yeah i don't have fun yeah
yeah you gotta have some fun dude i
don't know if did we ever release the
did we ever release that toyota podcast
or the we actually did a
read for them and then they asked us to
come back one more time oh wow yeah
yeah they don't care that's the other
thing a lot of them are just like
whatever some do though
yeah i'm trying to tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected